how to find your one word I mentioned in
a few of my videos that I think it's
important for entrepreneurs to get down
to one word that describes who they are
as a person and then bring that to your
business and for me I have the word
believe I believe in people and I apply
that to entrepreneurs and so when I'm
making decisions about what I'm gonna do
with my company it has to be things that
are around believing believing in
entrepreneurs and that makes it easy for
you to make decisions but it also makes
it easy for people to talk about you
because chances are you're not doing a
great job of marketing yourself you're
making it hard for people to spread the
message about you and you're not
bringing yourself fully to your business
when you have a one word message that
it's easy to share people will share it
they'll feel it they'll want to spread
the word if they believe the same thing
as you do so I got a question from one
of my youtube viewers and a great guy
who's who have talked a few times and
he's translated some of my videos in the
Spanish Arturo who wrote in to say what
happens when you have too many words and
can't decide so Arturo this video is for
you and what I'm gonna do is break down
how I got to my word believe' and this
is gonna be a little bit unfiltered I
haven't fully worked out the process as
an educational tool it's more just a
dump of the process that I went through
and hopefully you can learn from that it
started when I watched the movie job so
I loved Steve Jobs big fan of Steve Jobs
I went to see the movie Jobs and there
are a couple points in that movie where
I got the feeling of being excited and
you know that feeling you know the
feeling when you watch a movie or you
listen to a great song and you just you
get that feeling you get that feeling of
excitement and energy and you want to go
do something when you watch a movie like
jobs at least for me I felt I wanted to
go and do something make make my
business better you know you get that
sometimes when you're at a motivational
speech or you hear somebody talk or you
read a great book maybe you're watching
my videos you know you want to
get out there and take action and do
something and so I wanted something that
that could represent that for me I
wanted people that get that feeling when
they came to my website and learned
about me before all this my tagline was
over 14 million entrepreneurs helped and
Counting and adventure grew that over 20
million entrepreneurs helped in counting
and that was just a number of people who
have visited my website and I thought
and that's like that's like the
McDonald's slogan you know you walk down
you see McDonald's says how many
billions served and I thought that added
some credibility but that's not
something that people talk about right
nobody says oh Evans helped 20 million
entrepreneurs after I watched the movie
i sat down with Jason Vaughn seco who's
joined me and we've done some great
collaborations together and we tried to
come down to one sentence and the
sentence that we came down to let me
find it here actually have a document
that maybe I can show you guys is hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and I was
trying to narrow down my focus to make a
message that people could talk about and
this was something that Jason was a big
believer in and I got it down to hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help because it
explains the type of people who I wanted
to work with which was entrepreneurs
we're not just any entrepreneurs as
hungry entrepreneurs you know you'd want
to help the people were just sitting
there don't take action and I feel like
they deserve help and and I like helping
people and that and I feel like it's so
hard to be an entrepreneur that if you
are hungry and you're trying to make a
difference in this world you deserve to
be helped so something that I believed
in and that's the sense as we got down
to and Jason is going on is like wow
that's too long you know it's too many
syllables it's hard to share but let's
start with that and then I did some work
on my own I'm just trying to figure out
how to make that sentence shorter and
more impactful so I got the feeling and
I just made a list I just wrote down
some of the things that that got me
excited about my business I didn't know
where it was going it just did kind of a
dump so this would be the equivalent of
making a list of words so what I wrote
down was what I do what I believe but
not inspirational enough so that that
wasn't inspirational enough that
sentence so I put entrepreneurs change
the world entrepreneurs a heroes
celebrate entrepreneurs have
rallying cry gets your heart pumping and
then I tried to get to actually words
that that I could use as part of my
slogan so it's on you take your shot
believe follow your passion overcome
persevere keep going step up don't
settle start all kind of shorter and
more powerful more impactful words and I
settled on nothing at the end of that
day I looked at that list like I like
them all I don't know where I'm going
with this and I came back the next day
and I liked the word believe we just
kind of stuck with me and from there I
kind of expanded it to believe in what
you're doing which is passion believe
that you can do it which is confidence
and believe that it will work out with
conviction and that thought will believe
it's too short like I got to make it
longer I was fighting I was fighting how
short it was and so I came up with
believe you came believe in the possible
believe more believe it all believe in
belief believe and believe I was trying
to come up with something else and I got
frustrated with all of these and thought
that believe was the best one on that
list and it just kind of gave me the
confidence to say you know what I'm just
gonna I'm gonna stick with belief and
every thing I've done since then since
that day has been about believe and I've
updated my bio if you go to my my social
media BIOS that just says I believe I
hash tag believe in entrepreneurs it
just makes things so much easier it's
easier for people to spread the message
you see it at the end of the videos you
see how I talk about all the time and so
that's the process I went through again
I started with something I wanted to be
moving exciting passion something that I
looked at and got excited by I wrote
down a whole list of ideas and I just
left it for the day I came back the next
day and found the one that kind of
smoked me most and looked on different
variations variations of that and then
ended up with with just the one word and
and since then I've loved it and I've
used it every day and and it's helped me
make decisions for my business so
hopefully our true that helped to answer
your question maybe in the future as I
as I come with a more refined process
we'll make another video for you guys
but if you guys like this video you want
to see more give it a thumbs up below
you have a question
for me and you have a comment leave it
below I make a video response and if you
want to subscribe to the channel you can
click on my face there at the top left
hand corner or top right hand corner for
you left hand corner for me so thank you
and I'll see you soon